PROFESSOR 1: So we are here today
with Professor Allen Kachalia.
Allen is a physician.
He's also a lawyer and a professor
at Harvard Medical School.
ALLEN KACHALIA: When I
first went into medicine,
most of us who go into medicine, we
go in it to make patients feel better.
We realize that we don't necessarily
always do that because mistakes
happen right in front of us.
This is something is very preventable,
something that's in our control.
There's no reason for most of the
mistakes that happen to happen.
And we need to do a better job of
it because patients also trust us
when they come into the hospital.
I think many of us think
that when we go to hospitals,
they are safe places where we go to
recover where we go to get better.
They shouldn't be places
where we go and get hurt.
I think that I have a job
that has a great mix of work.
I went into medicine simply
because I knew that I
would enjoy taking care of patients.
I added a law degree to my
education because I wanted
to move into policy work later in life.
I wouldn't say lawyers are
the problem in the system.
I'd say the system is the problem.
In the United States, for every dollar
that we spend on liability insurance,
only about $0.40 makes it to a patient.
And I think we can do better than that.
Lawyers can help the system improve
by helping patients navigate
the system when patients
have been wrongfully injured
and they can't get
access to compensation.
They can help hold the right
systems and providers accountable.
They can also help patients negotiate
a quicker resolution or a quicker
settlement earlier
when it's more merited.
So they can really help us
deliver that accountability
signal that we want delivered.
Because patients on their own may
not know how to navigate the system.
So lawyers can really
help with that piece.